Hello.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hi, hi, welcome in, welcome in, welcome in.
Hello.
Early stream.
I don't think there's any saxophone in this.
This is not...
I guess this is a type of jazz, maybe.
It could use.
Hold on, I have it right here.
That's my Taco Bell.
Hmm...
Oh, wait, we're done.
Why did it stop?
Why chat freeze?
Hold on, let me try and fix it.
And... Frozen!
There you go.
So talented.
Thank you.
I love mint.
I love denser to duck.exe.
I hope you'll all cover ice cream one day together.
Maybe.
Cry on tight.
Sayoi Naka!
Happy birthday.
My tip for the day.
Each more.
Each.
Eat more.
Crunch wraps or preeps.
That's what this is.
Crunch wrap supreme is my lunch.
It's a crunch wrap supreme and it, it has a black bean.
A black bean one.
Yeah.
Jasmine toe is real.
You know what else is jazz?
Godot's theme.
Let me try it.
Any advice for this poor unprepared wish?
Hope you have a good stream.
Yes, good luck.
Show this, you know.
What does she know?
I know.
I'm going to cry.
Got the revenue, thank you.
I was trying to do it to, like, the beat of this, but then I
got all messed up.
stuff can you chew into the mic you have a strange request
thanks
minjo best advice one time i got lost coming home from
school and i knew how to get home from the 7-eleven when i
was walking i was like walking a really long time and the
sun was starting to set and i was like man i really don't
know where i am i Don't recognize this street at all!
And I went up to a lady who was on her front, in her yard,
like at the front door.
And I went to her and I said, Anno, Sumi Masen!
And then I was like,
She was so shocked!
She was like, and she drove me there
it was awesome no I was really lost and my mom was so
worried about me and she was like um where the hell were you
me and I said oh my god I'm my goal my goal bye-bye and
I told the judge I watch Mint YouTube Phantom and they let
me skip J.
Let's go.
Okay, well, I'm going to eat a little bit more.
I've been so...
You have a charmed life, Minky.
That's not even life.
I'm dead.
Yeah, that's a true story.
I have a bit of a headache.
And I think it's because...
of stress.
I took some medicine, but I'm also like, maybe it's because
I also didn't eat.
So, yesterday was my birthday!
Could I get possibly a happy birthday from my favorite
cosplay?
Oh, yeah!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
This game might not help with that.
Alright, let's go.
I should be good after this, but...
I need a napkin.
Let's play the game.
because I have, oh, sorry, I'm still on the the displays or
the options.
I have two streams today, so we'll be writing into my second
stream, probably maybe back to back.
So, cool!
Double Minky, Double Minky, but in the next one it'll be a
collab, so it'll be a little more difficult for me to like
talk to you guys, so I was like, oh, I have too much to yap!
So let's start this game, baby.
Oh,
Why are they speaking in English though?
Are we at Narita or we at Taneda?
Whoa!
Oh my gosh, it's a person!
Wait, this is what I've always wanted to do!
I've always wanted to be in a suitcase!
Because it's po-
I have to be careful about how I wiggle.
Whoa!
They wouldn't do...
Would they do that though?
Would they like notice that you're a person in there and
then...
steal you?
The intro is very stylish.
This is so like...
It reminds me of like a...
How do you say?
Like an old jazzy cartoon.
Like a spy cartoon.
They get scanned!
They would know I'm in there!
Oh my god, bird strike!
Wait, actually!
They don't pressurize the cabin hold.
Oh, it's okay.
I'm already goo, so...
Oh, I don't want to
like close my eyes and just jam, but I want to keep watching
too.
Wow!
This is cool.
Whoa, my sensitivity...
Did they... Wait, whoa, whoa, the sensitivity is like
actually insane.
Hold on.
Controls?
Input?
Oh, here we go, here we go.
Now sensitivity.
Like half that.
A little bit more.
1,000 times sensitivity.
What if I...
That wasn't even full sensitivity.
Let's see what full is.
Holy cow.
Okay, I'm trying to look forward.
Only a psychopath would play like this.
Oh my gosh.
I'm even going to turn it down even more.
And like, turn off some of the smoothing.
Oh, whoops.
Ah!
This feels good.
It's never excited to watch you!
32 debut this friday today's also my birthday happy birthday
happy birthday all right cool well we can't go to the street
we're here in darlington
darlington who this original turning finances are
Just a box.
Import, export.
Can I run?
Oh, what about you?
Are you just a box, too?
This one looks like a bomb.
Brooker and Brewster.
Velocipede.
What the heck is that?
More boxes.
Why is there an office in the subway?
Wait.
Down, honey.
The director will be right with you.
Oh, are there subtitles?
One second.
Sorry, I keep clicking objectives.
Display.
No.
Input.
Control.
I like how it says joystick one, button one, but I'm not
using
Sorry, but there's none, it seems.
They are always on.
Yes, but no.
Okay.
Subtitles are part of the game.
Okay, well maybe she's not important enough.
She's Secretary the 9th.
Yes?
So sorry.
Continue your work.
I'm just seeing what you've got going on.
She's typing math!
Oh my god.
God, we have Einstein over here.
What is going on?
Oh.
Saxophone lessons.
Acoustic or piezoelectric.
Group or private lessons.
Chords or style letters.
You choose the style you want to learn.
Rate is 45k yen an hour.
Please call Mr. Livermore.
Why is everything...
Why are we...
Are we in Japan?
Hello to my tiny little mini and precious minto.
Paiso.
We're in jazz pan.
Marzipan?
Maybe.
How do you say it?
Paiso.
And then someone's selling their car.
This is manual.
You guys know how to drive manual.
Wait.
Yeah, you know how to drive manual?
It's like Piazzo.
Oh.
Piazzo.
Only Americans don't.
Why?
That's not true.
It's normal to drive manual here.
Really?
Where are you?
Okay.
Isn't this word, Chebo?
I don't know how it's Korean.
Isn't that like the word for like the son or daughter of a
very rich family?
Docs yourself now.
Yeah, tell me now, tell me now.
Wealthy air, yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uranium rods?
Call Blake.
Blake's got your...
I like the seats are...
Wait, hold on.
I'm still looking around.
Reader's digestive organs!
Black Market Price Guide!
Oh.
Playbot!
What does it mean for me?
I think.
Okay.
Peruse the articles.
The director is ready for you.
Already?
oh okay oh please have a seat we much business to discuss
please have a seat no hi i'm gonna get go you're gonna laugh
at me i think i think i already know what's gonna happen
here
the Soviet Consulate.
Am I a spy?
Basically, we need you to infiltrate the Soviet Consulate.
He doesn't even say anything about it.
They've taken some of our important technology, and it's
imperative that we get it back on the right hand.
Is he gonna look at it?
As per usual, here's your mission or subscription.
Don't take too many.
Okay.
If you need me, I'll be in the wine cellar.
There's stairs there?
it wasn't me if i sit back down it won't let me what do we
got here take one capsule every mission or until reality is
sufficiently augmented mission mission mission oil mission
oil am amphibomine dextrose Cool.
What do I do with this?
Oh, what the hell?
There's no stairs.
Oh.
Okay.
We're going?
Exciting!
Oh, infiltrate the Soviet consulate!
What's over here?
Hello?
Are you also infiltrating?
Believe in yourself.
Why are the people...
The cars are crazy.
Everything's crazy.
Believe in me.
Oh my god, I can't...
Sorry I haven't been around as much.
I'm going to congratulate you on this too.
Dang, it might die so fast.
It's all about the jazz, man.
Oh, he could take his money.
I'm not going to do that.
He's doing a good job.
What's this?
Jazz punk.
Wait, I'll take that.
I'll take that home with me.
Never mind.
I'll calibrate your sunset for a dollar.
Just a dollar?
Am I turning you on?
I reboot when I want.
You know, I tried online dating, but I couldn't find it in a
penis match.
A what?
There were no subs- but a what?
Oh, you.
Only if you're using crypto.
I swear my animals raised for 10,000 volts.
What's this guy?
Psst.
Take this degausser.
Use it to scramble three carrier frequency pigeons.
Hit each pigeon three times in order to degauss it.
Three... what?
I'm already so...
Ha.
I'm already so ha.
Hello?
I need to find a pit- You're the 1,032nd player to inspect
the garbage!
Okay!
I gotta blast some pigeons.
Oh!
My fist?
My very hairy fist.
No one's held.
How's the audio, by the way?
I'm pretty sure he stole my laptop.
No, I didn't.
I don't even know who you are.
Oh, I got Pax's piece of crap.
Why is he...
Bruce, sorry, sorry, sorry, I stole my laptop.
You gotta get your own peanut butter.
Okay.
It's a pizza code.
Chose, think pizza.
Pizza initiated.
Oh, oh my god.
I'm playing another game suddenly.
I'm playing a pizza game.
What is happening?
Is this pizza zombie?
Ah!
I think so.
Oh, how old Joe?
Oh my god.
Suddenly I'm playing another game.
He's...
He's not feeling very good, huh?
What's this one?
Dual wielding!
Oh, ow!
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god, it's horrible.
It's horrible.
Wait, why don't they die?
That guy is still rolling around.
There he goes.
Slender punk eight slices.
Why am I suddenly playing pizza game?
Oh my god, the clouds are Butchroop!
Why is the floor pizza?
Guy Savage.
Wish I said we're this good.
What are these?
That's not part of my pizza.
I'll kill you.
Ouch, ouch.
Can I die on this?
I wonder.
Oh my god.
I'm trying to slice and dice you.
Okay, it's not like a...
What's the word?
It's not a, if I hold down click, it just automatically, you
know.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, there we go.
Is that kiwi?
I've put kiwi on pizza before.
Curious.
Not many people have done that, I think.
This looks like a secret.
Oh.
A fish.
All work and no playbook.
makes oh my god scary did
that do something or closed for no reason the music is so
loud in my ear gone fishing all right we gotta find some
pigeons no okay thank goodness the music kind of oh
Okay, aiming is essential.
Okay, I got one pigeon!
Hello.
Can I interest you in the stick of cotton?
Yes.
Did it drop something?
I'm not sure.
Oh.
My eyes.
Oh my god.
No!
Oh my god, he's dodging him.
He's so talented.
Never punished.
Oh my god.
How is he still...
How is it?
He might be the luckiest guy ever.
Get up, sir!
Get up!
Oh my god, he might be the luckiest guy ever.
Oh my god!
He's nearly escaping death on every...
Wait,
don't go back the other way.
Oh, geez.
Okay, wait.
Hold on, I'm gonna go see if that bird dropped something.
I wish I could turn down them.
Oh, it did.
Oh!
Ooh, dipid pigeon.
How are you so loud?
Seriously.
Oh, get me out of here.
Get a jab.
I'm sorry.
Did I say it's 2,500 yen for a newspaper?
Everybody talks.
Okay.
I did notice this.
thought we were going to pick it up.
I didn't think it would be used for murder.
It's just in the middle of the road.
Maybe I'm trying to kill all my...
Okay.
Yeah!
I really didn't notice that I dropped something before.
Thanks, guys.
Do I have something on my face?
Oh.
Yes?
Oh, my God.
Why do I feel like I'm playing like a modern version of
that...
possible quiz game.
Okay, I love you.
Bye-bye.
Well done.
I can't do it anymore, you guys.
I can't do it.
There is no sound option.
That's fine.
We got more Ode to Pigeon.
What are you doing?
Do you have the MacGuffin?
A whata?
Come back when you've got the MacGuffin.
Okay.
Who's just playing music?
The president steps down onto the ground after descending
the ladder.
The McMuffin.
Oh, who are you?
You.
My aim.
He's like right there.
All right, our third.
return to the informant can I make anyone smell like pigeon
oh I got an achievement which said spray three people with
pheromones but I definitely didn't do that I only sprayed
one guy he's one with the pigeon now Yeah.
Oh, what's this?
Temporal shifting decriminalized.
Time heads celebrate by going back in time.
Mega Corp CEO declares Uno.
Oh no, he's gonna win the game!
We still haven't even checked out the other side of the
street.
Alright, our informant was this guy over here, no?
Oh my god.
Thanks for collecting the pigeons.
You're welcome.
This is my Mima's secret pigeon pot pie recipe.
Oh!
No!
Don't hurt it!
Please wait while they bake.
Just like Mewa I used to make.
I have fourth degree burns all over my entire face.
Skeleton, thank you!
Ah, it burns.
Ah, I have fourth degree burns all over my entire face.
Aw.
Wait, what if I...
Oh, I have no more stuff anymore.
You don't know me?
What's my name?
Okay, but only if you use polarity protection.
Her name is...
My wife.
Condemned due to swan infestation.
This place is bizarre, isn't it?
I don't
know.
I just get ball.
Oh.
Can I do anything with it?
No?
Oh.
That's not.
Bop, bop.
What's going on here?
I'm investigating trash again.
Wait?
Extra strength plus C-backs.
Oh, I drank it.
Oh, my God.
Never take Plessy Bex after taking Mission Oil.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I didn't mean to!
I didn't mean to take it!
I think the game didn't like...
I think I messed up.
Let me go back there.
Bop, bop, bop, bop.
Bop, bop, bop, bop, bop.
Boooo.
Ah,
let's talk to three inanimate cardboard boxes.
The Metal Gearhead and me has to.
The path you walk has no end.
Each step you take is paved with the corpses of your
enemies.
Their souls will haunt you forever.
You shall have no peace.
Hear me, snake.
My spirit will be watching you, covered in pigeons.
for salmon spawning season.
Ah!
Don't scare me!
Oh, he's yelling, he's like, aw.
Ah.
Into the street you go, into the street.
It's like it's like I turned into a high school bully a
sound oh I just ate this the trash sandwich It looked
perfectly fine though.
I think Fish and chips Hello, my name is Johnny to Johnny to
hello my mother never thought me to speak and smell She's
just consuming everything.
I can't stop!
I'm so hungry!
I got an idea.
What's that?
Push this button.
He said push this button but the subtitle says pull my
finger.
Johnny!
John!
Oh my gosh.
Don't scare me like that!
Good thing I have quicksave.
I'm superior to a trash can in almost every way.
I can modulate my voice all day long.
Why do you humans insist on including your epidermis?
Are you a person or an antelope?
I don't know anywhere.
I wish more people were like you.
I'm so...
Nice.
I think.
Creepy.
Yeah, what's up?
Free Wi-Fi from Starbucks.
Creepy.
But I dropped my password cracker on the road.
I played Frogger!
Oh my god.
Oh!
It's okay.
We can go backwards.
Probably.
Do I have to come back?
Okay.
Oh shoot.
I made it.
How do you drop it there?
Probably took the shortcut, you know?
That was so stinking close.
Put it on.
Amphibian data visor!
I liked eight data packets to crack the network.
Oh my god.
I have no saliva.
Okay.
Is that a data cracker?
Oh, I see one.
Oh.
Then you.
I have four out of eight.
Oh, here's one.
Um...
And one.
Password?
One more?
Gamers don't look up?
But I do.
Starbucks guest?
Alright, biggie.
Now a little privacy, please.
Oh my god.
What's he watching?
What is that?
What is it?
He's funny.
Privacy!
Sorry, sorry, sorry!
Oh, Titus, you came home!
Oh my gosh, it spooked me so loud.
Types that are fired!
And Nyak pleads insanity.
Can I go in here?
We specialize in laundering your stolen goods.
I think I should be able to go in there.
What about here?
I ate some.
Now I'm bursting with energy.
Oh, the fish and chips.
Customer reaction has been overwhelming.
I think Comic Sans is very...
Oh, this guy's stuck.
You're late.
Oh, I am.
Side quest.
I guess we could do a side quest, right?
What is this?
You find the mailbox marked with chalk on the side.
You will see further instructions from there.
Okay.
Yeah, the Geiger counter is kind of going insane.
Underwear and underwear.
No, wait.
We're everywhere and underwear.
I could tell you, but then I have to kill you.
Oh.
And then I have to resurrect you.
Locate the mailbox marked with chalk.
Mailbox marked with chalk.
Ah, ah, he goes MC Square.
There's a man in the park sitting on a bench.
Deliver this package to him.
Yes, sir.
Man, on the park.
I thought that was a person up there.
In the bench, on the bench.
Sitting on the bench.
Wait, which guy?
I think it has to be this one, right?
Or it's the unassuming guy.
Do you want this?
No.
Have a seat, but keep your eye.
Locate the newspaper box marked with a piece of chewing gum.
Newspaper box marked with chewing gum.
Yes, sir.
Can I just go in?
You know, I didn't even really think about it much.
I didn't try to infiltrate at all.
Feel lost, stuck in life?
Call the hint helpline.
We'll set you on the right path.
5-5-5 hint.
Nippon Telnet.
5-5-5-5.
It's an hint.
Workers take their lunch break at noon.
Oh, oh, oh, whoops, my bad.
It's an actual hint.
Oh, oh.
That's not my hand.
What am I doing?
What was it?
Look for the chewing gum.
Oh, I was wondering if there was fall damage.
Oh, I know if it's marked in gum.
There's still shiny pig- No, Revenge of the Pigeon!
That's terrible.
Hello, Mint, please give me a hint.
Try again later.
Big boy.
Oh, here we go.
You're almost there, Agent.
Go to the Raytheon Motel.
Knock on the door using the secret knock.
Do not correctly, and you'll be led inside.
The what hotel?
The Raytheon Motel.
This one over here.
This is the one I tried knocking on before, I think.
Uh, here?
Yes.
Okay, we got this.
Oh my gosh, peace and quiet.
Okay.
Watch this.
Wait, watch this.
Watch, watch, watch, mom.
Watch this.
It is later.
I'm here again.
Please, please, please.
Use this money to avoid your taxes.
Thanks.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
You've made it.
Yeah?
This carrier frequency pigeon possesses top secret
information.
it into the next level by any means necessary next level
don't let us down okay well done oh we'll be keeping an eye
on him i think i i think i swallowed him this trench coat's
made of the finest bald eagle pelts i think i ate the the
bird look how cute they are can i leave from here i don't
think so all right well cool we did the side quest
all right so we still haven't even explored everything so
let's head back down here
okay i like how the text is still on the ground have i gone
into the apartments oh no this is the salmon
who's blowing raspberries at me Is that revenge for it
pooping on you?
Oh, maybe.
What's going on here?
Movie theater?
The show is starting shortly.
Retirement is bliss.
Why is there just stuff on the...
Oh.
Oh, my God.
I keep a go- they keep me a cigar!
It's a what?
It's a swing wing.
It's a wing wing.
Is this a real toy for this?
It's a what?
It's a swing wing.
It's the swing wing.
Oh my god.
Just give your own kids shaking baby syndrome.
What is happening?
Oh my god.
A new thing.
It's the swing wing.
Get swing wing made by transagram where the fun comes from.
It's a swing wing.
It's a what?
I can't get...
Oh my god.
Wait, can I get out?
Can I leave, please?
Oh god.
Oh, what's happened?
Oh, I've been given...
They took my cigar!
I've been given...
Is this popcorn?
I don't really
care if you leave now.
You've already paid me an admission.
I mean, who stays for the real film anyway, right?
All right.
Well, we watched the movie.
Wait, can I see the movie?
If I go back in...
Oh, but no!
Get me out of here, please!
I should have known.
Weeks of fun, weeks of fun!
Lifetime of chiropractor bills.
It's the swing wing.
The girl's face kills me.
Get that away from that elephant!
I almost called him a dinosaur.
see his big thing and it's like dinosaur.
Okay, good.
We're back out.
It's the swing wing.
It is like a dinosaur, right?
Almost.
You're so small.
That was the movie.
Oh, gee.
A bootleg VHS.
Just for me.
What?
Pow.
I've been smoking since I was three.
Still no side effects.
I'm 34 years old.
Oh.
Pau.
I've been smoking since I was three.
Still no side effects.
Don't smoke, everybody.
Don't do it.
How many things do you call a dinosaur then?
Best friends forever.
Try to wear you sleep at night.
Oh, I don't like that.
response all right we're gonna infiltrate the soviet
consulate right now it's not noon these guys are not on
break but i might be able to go in i can just go inside
they're still fired they have the news is so slow hello i'm
afraid you don't have appointment
I'm not sure what that did.
I'm sorry, I cannot allow you access.
What have we got in here?
Lunchtime, communist plotting, vodka and biscuits, potato
sack rice.
You have insufficient security clearance.
Let me in.
I'm afraid I must ask you off premises.
So, it's actually quite late.
How do I restart the day then?
What is this?
What is that, dude?
Can you click the clock?
I tried, but let me try again.
Maybe we can, like, set it to...
Oh, where's to be going now?
Oh, I can!
I can!
I'm silly.
Noon exact.
Okay, oh, hello.
That's fine.
Gone luncheon.
Back in five minutes.
Okay, we only have five minutes, you guys.
We gotta get up there.
We gotta get in.
I'm just so curious what else we could do here, you know.
Okay, I'm infiltrating.
And three, two, one.
Oh, sick.
Okay.
What do I do now?
Um...
Oh my god, it's so loud every time.
Uneventful news day seizes a nation!
Moon explode!
That's...
Uneventful, of course.
Top secret.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, oh, oh, don't...
Don't, don't, don't, don't do...
Don't do my...
Hi!
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
Oh.
I'm destroying my own thing.
Unless that's not my thing.
Who knows?
Wait.
There we go.
Defeat a microscopic squadron of buck...
Said something for sure.
There was text.
That was spoken.
This one's funky.
Wait, are they gonna mitosis in front of us?
Oh, hello.
Even he's got a cigarette.
Everyone, do be smoking.
Mainframe of the month.
Is this my disguise?
All I need is a human heart.
What were we trying to get in here again?
I can't remember.
There's so many noises.
What's happening here?
Whoa.
We have comrade crunch.
There's a whistle inside.
Stay communist even in the milk of a capitalist pig.
Wait, what does this do?
Okay.
The tone of...
Do I have to change it?
There's so many signals.
There's so many things.
The toy.
Oh, here.
Did it say 2600?
Ah!
It even...
It's like, hey, stupid.
No!
A dope pay-per-view?
Oh, and the direct-
I'm not a zoomer!
We maxed it!
One.
I want to call Satan.
Two.
Three.
A pie?
Okay, see you later.
See you girl.
Cool.
What else we got on here?
They
couldn't max it out again, right?
What do you say?
Okay, I think I got all the options, so...
Very cool.
Target acquired!
Very good.
What is this for?
It makes them sing.
What is this now?
Oh, oh.
Looks a little dangerous.
It's a booty enhancer!
From the radiation!
Oh, there's so many!
Why did it make like five copies?
Look!
Wait, can I put the employee?
Oh wait, no?
Interesting, okay.
There's so many sounds.
Wait, do I use his eye to get in here?
This guy.
Thanks.
All right, let's go.
Ice alarm or fire alarm?
Floor lubricant.
Whoa!
Whoa, it's really slippery guys, be careful.
Pull the ice alarm!
Wait, do these work?
Oh, no.
No.
Huh.
I think I pull it and then maybe go down the chute.
Whoa!
Wait, but this caught...
Oh, so it caused a fire.
Smuggle a carrier pigeon into the next level.
Oh, I'm here.
Eat your bread.
Nobody's eating it.
We arrived in Japan or something.
Welcome back.
No!
Our benefactors used to extend their grata to...
My bread!
I hope you're ready for another job.
There's a biotech engineer working for Rayfield Corps.
Inside connections seem to have afforded him a particularly
valuable artificial kidney.
Estimated value on the red market is over 25 billion yen.
We need you to extract this from them at any cost.
Job carrying the carrier, thank you.
If it was, I know you'll do well by me.
Yep.
But if you don't mind, I've got a landline to install.
His shoes!
This is his favorite restaurant.
I actually... wait, this is such a cute design.
It's like a...
It's like a Manikineko, but it's also an octopus.
This game is...
Guys, I think this game might be a little goofy.
Let's take my meds.
Squid!
You know what I meant.
that's our target follow the cowboy okay
i don't like that that just happened to us i think that made
me upset
What do they mean they make ropes?
Oh, hi.
Uh, what is this car?
Uh, go ahead.
This car?
Um, what is this car?
Well, nobody can say I didn't try it.
You know?
Oh, there he is.
I mean, there's a cigarette.
That's not him.
Watashi, very welcome.
Watashi has a cash.
Why you click on me?
Oh.
I'm just talking to you.
You could get the multivibrator.
Oh.
It's impolite to ask a lady her fun way.
I didn't ask.
How big is your creation mesh?
No instant messaging.
Kawarid.
Do you like me in kimono or kisario?
She sounds like me when I turn the...
Oh, wrong way.
The voice takes around.
Do you like me in...
Does this kimono make me look fat 32?
That's it.
This came a little
strange!
Why?
Like as hard as but low.
I don't get it.
Anyway.
Whoa, what's here?
Talk to me!
Don't ignore me!
What's in here?
Oh!
Virus.
Uh-oh.
Um, guys!
Kimono makes her look ex-fat.
Is that a good thing?
Is that guy peeing?
Yes?
Take my advice.
Yep.
Never overclock your underwear.
Can you spare my tea?
I'd like to drink motor oil.
Ah, the government.
Ah, it's the government.
Can you give me a nibble of that cookie?
Ah, the government.
Is that guy throwing up?
No, he's...
Oh, he's eating it!
And then he's gonna eat me!
Oh my god!
Oh, I thought it was a cup of tea, but it's just the latter
floating in cyber space.
race or something.
Do not eat.
Oh, I thought it was orange pico.
It tastes like chalk.
Sometimes I threw up things that I don't remember eating.
So he, close enough, throwing up.
Is he eating the rest of it?
Oh my god.
Ew, stop making noises behind me.
Wait, was there anything around here?
Can we go in here?
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, Yes?
She was so polite about it.
My thrash shop has been infested with vases.
I mean, opposite of that.
Sorry.
My thrash shop has been infested.
Here we go.
Oh, oh my god.
Ah!
But I'm...
Oh my god.
Don't knock over the vases, though.
Wait, I can do this.
I can do this.
Yes!
There's only like two in here.
Wait, did I get it?
Oh, I did, I did, okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oops.
Oh, I did it!
She didn't even get mad.
She didn't care at all.
At least I can cook these fries for dinner.
Fry soup for everyone.
She says, what she says and what she thinks are totally
opposite.
Did you know that?
At least I can cook this rice for dinner.
Is he saying rice soup for everyone?
Yeah, you naughty fly.
Yeah, I...
Look at you.
With your booty in the air.
You stay down there.
Oh, I have a fly's water now.
Oh!
Are they all?
Okay, that guy's not a fly.
What about you?
They're all flies.
Am I supposed to find all the fly people?
Am I what?
Okay.
Well, yeah, we're supposed to follow the cowboy, huh?
Let's go find him.
Soup desuio.
Oh, oh!
Excuse you.
Milk.
Oh, sorry.
Can we talk?
Really?
Oh, hontoni.
What's in here?
Oh, this is where you call the hint, right?
Okay, we don't need a hint, though.
Not yet.
I don't think I've lost.
I haven't even explored it.
YAMETE?
What is your business here?
Um...
I'm being ultra-cawaii.
I'm taking you in.
Ah!
Why?
Stop resisting.
Let me get you with my fly's water!
Why?
Oh, my...
Oh, my God.
Oh, I see.
I became a wizard.
How?
How high can we get him?
Yes!
The force!
I've had a cadaver!
Did I win or...
Why do you take me in anyway?
Wait, what am I supposed to do with these hands?
What am I supposed to do with these hands?
Oh.
Leave them, I guess.
What's here?
Oh, oh, it's a sax!
Oh my god, wait.
There's gotta be...
There's gotta be kazoo or something in here.
I think we found everything, maybe.
Oh, what's this?
Okay, it's jazz.
Jazz is not dead.
What am I doing with...
Oh, oh!
He's bisoned bird purring.
Hello.
I wonder where the cow...
Boy went.
Oh.
hello you intrigued me come here i got a job for you what's
that i need your blanks i need the old knife jagger i'm
replicants i'm back oh no here what do you say blanks will
you do one old-timey one for me for old-timey sake this
blade rudder yes i need you to track him down and retire the
barrier in the immediate area you can't leave until you
catch them all etc take this with you avoid cough machine
it'll detect whether someone's a real placent or a pile of
bananas or whatever yeah try it out on yours truly what if
you are see a piece of cake okay
what a replicant looks like?
It looks like a human?
Oh, oh my gosh.
It looks like the Metal Gear font.
It looks like a Metal Gear.
Wait, side quest.
Retire the replicants.
Okay.
So is that a replicant?
What the?
It's two minutes from each go.
Table for one, please.
Mint ketchup.
Could be Snatcher.
Yeah, exactly.
So the replicants, I'm guessing, they look like...
Like this!
Now how do I kill you?
Whoa, freaky.
Oh, replicant detected, yes!
Oh, that wasn't so bad.
Oh, he's retiring!
Oh, sweet guy!
Congratulations!
Oh, what about you?
I didn't see you even.
Oh, that is a fish.
Identification pilot.
Wait, I do need to get closer.
Okay,
these guys are...
The children laughing.
Okay.
Well, we found one.
Those are my hands.
They're just stuck there.
Very cool.
This gotta be one.
A gold watch?
I'm headed to the pawn shop.
Okay, that's two?
You think it's the bird?
Nah.
Just a bird.
A boar.
A little boar.
Wait, but everybody else was...
Hmm.
Oh, unless in the tunnel, I don't think I went in here.
Okay.
It's gotta be this guy.
This is our man!
Oh,
finally I can retire in peace.
Retiring to the chief.
Hello.
You're a renegade, Polyblank.
A loose cannon.
Uh-huh.
I said retire.
I didn't mean retirement.
Oh.
I meant dead meat.
I'm afraid I'm going to have to ask for your badge.
No!
Please!
And your gun.
And your other gun.
But not my third gun, right?
And your other badge.
Oh, my other badge!
And your badge gun.
And your gun badge.
Get the hell out of my...
office you're a disgrace to the force no please god i can't
believe i was married to a real placid did you say real
placid or replicant all those years our marriage was a sham
oh my god he's telling us the drama now god i miss you makes
me sick now get out of my sight i gotta take a nap nap time
god i can't put oh he really is taking a nap in your metal
gear box I'm trying to get some shut-eye.
I'm trying to take my stuff back.
Dang it.
Automatic.
Wait, autonomic teller machine.
Wait, what am I doing?
Huh?
Oh, I'm playing another game.
Another game within the game.
I have my swatter.
This, this feels so, uh, Blade Runner.
Oh, there's something over there, though.
The bank.
Hey, Queens.
I'm Cassette, and this is my elite crew of bad ass
motherfuckers.
Yeah!
Okay, Cassette.
I hate corporations.
Yeah!
Down with corporations!
Nap time, chat.
certificate that's tough what about you i'm cynthia cynthia
i crack wi-fi and i break hard i got an idea let's go rob
that bank yeah so first off we're gonna need some sneeze
wear that cracks sneeze wear okay what's a sneeze wear we
need those parts to build a sneeze wear device what's a
sneeze wear look like okay i saw i saw proper lounge Is this
sneeze wear?
How can I know?
I've never seen- I've never- I can't even sneeze on stream
when I want to!
It's so dark.
I can't see anything.
Is this sneeze wear?
Will I- will it be very obvious?
That looks like a man.
Does he know?
Wait, this looks like sneeze wear.
Oh, it's a gun.
Hey everyone, look at me.
I'm inside of a computer.
terabytes yeah terabytes people always ask me hey what do
you carry around in that vandal universe
and i tell them well it's just filled full of uh bites and
bits uh nibbles bites and bits and nibbles you know this
vandal's really just full of human bones hey ma look at me
i'm in the internet i am the matrix i am the matrix okay so
the gun was a was a was a sneeze oh i think i see another
next to red man i am the matrix who are you oh you are just
the red man that's that's all you it's all you've got he's
like i got one stick and i do it well oh i'm missing a part
though wait is that a part down there.
I don't remember if that was glowing before.
Oh, it is!
Wait, is that a nose?
Yeah!
Found Albert and the gang here.
Oh!
It's cool.
Okay, so you got the sneeze wear.
Next up, you need to load it with a virus.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, we're sneezing.
We're like sniffing it up.
We're kidding.
We're charging up our sneeze wear.
We gotta get real sick.
Can I charge it with fire?
No.
Okay.
We're sniffing and snuffing.
We're...
We're getting real sniffly.
I just need one more.
Okay, cool.
That's healthy fire.
Yeah, yeah.
Now you're ready to crack vault security.
Oh, yeah.
Deploy the virus.
Crash the system.
Okay.
You know, we used to use software, but the bank got onto us.
Now you're ready to crack vault security.
Okay, I'm gonna go.
Do I just sneeze on them?
Maybe they're like...
Oh, what's this guy?
Oh.
Oh, maybe if I want to...
What's over here or anything?
Nah.
Sniffer.
I have my eye on you.
I don't like you.
Hachoo, hachoo!
Hello.
I don't trust you.
Let me see your identification.
Akshu!
I am defeated.
Bless you, thank you.
Welcome to Muruf's Chemical Vault Access.
Oh!
It's a... Oh, I was gonna say it's a heist.
I had a crush on her.
A better heist than the Lulz!
Okay!
What am I grabbing?
Oh, nice.
How much money should I be getting?
It seems like a healthy amount of money.
Before taxes.
Is this good enough or...
Look up?
Is there some more here?
I think I got all of it, right?
Uh...
Look down.
Eh?
Uh-oh.
I think they're coming for me.
Um...
Oh,
I could just suck up the people.
Ah!
This sucks.
I'm just leaving!
I have my eye on you.
I guess that means more yen for us, huh?
Yeah.
Wait, I just have this guy in my...
I like your attitude, Polyblank.
Thanks.
Hey, you seem pretty cool.
How do I get in here?
Thanks.
Awesome.
I guess that means more yen for us, huh?
Oh, there we go.
All right.
Now just open the door.
Polyblank?
Polyblank, let me in.
What the hell, Polyblank?
Oh.
No way.
Oh my god, I ran off with the money!
Nobody noticed the band-aid?
Oh, I definitely noticed the band-aid.
Wait, did I get all that money?
Or...
Oh, my hands.
That's right.
They're not my real hands.
Closed 24-7.
Dang it.
I've been disarmed.
What's happening here?
Wait, what's going on over here real quick?
Oh, that's his favorite restaurant!
Okay, we found it.
Pointo!
Wait.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, sorry.
Do you have a reservation?
Do I need a reservation?
Best in town, they say, huh?
Everything sounds like that's all busty today.
He's all ears.
Oh, I can't clean his ears.
That feels weird.
steep sandwich my ear nose and throat feel so uncongested ah
that's much better oh he liked it though so this yo
lank master vidicon director's cut oh hello try electric
squid at your three o'clock The fly detector.
I don't have a fly detector.
Oh, I'm the fly detector.
Absolutely.
So what do we have going on up?
You're still...
You're still here.
Delicious lemonade for sale.
Wow, that's pretty pricey for some lemonade, though.
Better be good.
Yes, Matarikon.
I
don't know what he was.
What is it?
Ah!
Oh!
Have you been...
I thought...
Wait.
I thought it was his cigarette.
What is...
Oh!
What do you guys want to try?
Snaky Serum!
Or coffee tooth.
No, I gotta get the snake serum.
5.6% soldier free!
This has to be him!
What a thrill.
Whoa!
What the hell?
Um, no, I definitely...
There's a whole...
everything upstairs too oh my gosh this place is humongous i
got got twice snake drinker what is this oh i challenge you
volley blank to the ultimate wrestling match oh yeah you
think you got what it takes to take on me oh psycho johnny
mania Oh my gosh.
We're in Psycho Johnny Mania.
What's going on?
Awesome.
No hard feelings, right?
And now entering the ring, a new challenger, Polly Brow!
Brow!
And in this corner, ten-time heavyweight world champion
world champion?
Go maniac!
What do you intend to do to Polyblank?
Come here, my ten-inch guns got your name on them.
Ooh, I have Johnny Psycho Ten-inch gun.
Johnny Psycho Ten-inch gun.
There you have it, ladies and gentlemen.
The insane rankings of a madman.
Oh, oops.
And you, Polyblank, do you have any words for Mr.
Psychopath?
I'm gonna eat his guts!
Oh my god.
Where'd he go?
Oh.
I don't even know what I'm saying.
I'm just frothing at the mouth.
Oh yeah.
My insides.
Spectacular.
Yeah!
Just fired up.
Wait!
Space!
E!
Spam E!
Oh okay.
Okay, I'm back up.
We're fine.
Everything's cool.
He's almost down?
Thank you on this round, Polyblank.
But you'll be back.
I'll see you at the next Psychomania Challenge.
Total knockout.
You are the ultimate heavyweight champion of the world.
Of the world!
Now that you've won, what do you intend to do?
Fascinating.
Back to you in the studio.
Well, look, you's back for more punishment.
Where did I come from?
Oh, this is where we got our snake drink?
This way, I think we haven't been yet.
Steamy.
Hello.
What's this?
A baby.
Aren't you supposed to be following a cowboy?
Yeah.
Um.
Yes.
We have to go into the restaurant.
We'll go now.
This way.
Please take off your shoes.
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
In the whole thing?
No entrance, please.
What kind of food do they have here?
there sushi wait I said one out of five of what what am I
getting hello I love me some sushi haha loves me some sushi
yeah I mean I'll tell you that is the best sushi you get in
town oh the only thing here I don't judge is the Fugu oh I
don't blame you actually you know they actually let me keep
my shoes on Wow They're working in their corpse on like 17
years.
My grandpapa raised me to be a text instrument, ma'am.
Why, yes, I do have a fancy kidney.
Thanks, he's for noticing.
You're going to go see John the Cash Live.
That's very kind of you to notice this new hat.
My bad.
Look at my feet.
Oh, no, it's one of these toilets.
I'll rescue you.
Those are the worst.
Oh, oh, oh.
I don't know why I'm collecting spiders, but that's what I'm
doing now.
That's my new hobby.
It's collecting spiders for some reason.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Gamers don't look up.
Okay, just two more.
We got this.
Underneath.
Around the co- Hello.
Anything back there?
The Fogel!
I don't know why I'm collecting these, but...
Also, I am terrified of spiders.
Oh!
Stuff only.
That's why.
I've seen at least five spiders in here.
Okay, thank you.
Well, I've got...
Wait.
He's a pagan customer.
How am I supposed to...
kill him from this dinner.
Spider attack!
You have poor Fugu a technique.
Oh.
I'm not sure if this is what I'm supposed to do.
Oh!
You have restored blindness upon me.
Blinding soup!
Oh, I have been defiled.
We took all of his sins.
Blinding stew!
I was born and raised on a ranch farm.
There we go.
There's a pool you can order them through the mail!
Oh, I'll go by sick.
Oh,
oh my god.
Oh, I missed this guy.
You have yourself a wonderful evening.
He just, he launched his whole stomach.
Target acquired.
Uh, I'm not sure where I go with this.
here.
Would you like me to wrap that up for you?
No, thank you.
I'd just like my shoes back.
Enjoy your night.
Oh.
Okay.
Uh, can I leave?
Oh, there we go.
Darlington Station.
Are they coming after me?
They're coming for me.
That's fine.
We'll go this way yeah we broke the text oh uh oh bowling
joke no oh my god i'm scared oh bowling bowling this is your
last chance we've tried to reason with you spare me Bowling
jug!
She missed all the bowling jokes.
What?
He literally said bowling joke!
I have a candle.
It's the praying mantis.
He's hitting the fly.
What?
Dang it.
Sounds like an apple.
What's that guy doing down there, I wonder?
Oh my gosh, the apple.
Oh,
did that say light, the incense?
Oh, and then kneel.
Ooh, okay.
Hit the gong.
Fantastic work.
Thank you.
Now I can finally make my state and kidney pie.
That last drop seems to have attracted us a bit more heat
than usual.
What's going on?
We'll have to wait for things to cool down a bit.
In the meantime, I'll set you up for a vacation.
Vacation oil.
All expenses paid trip to Kaitech Resorts.
Go on.
Get some warranty.
Thank you.
You look like you can use it.
I think I'm being good.
I take it with no choice.
Brasilia.
I'm going to Brazil.
And I'm going to eat some more of my Taco Bell.
Am I going?
Or...
Oh.
Wait, am I going from Brazil?
Oh my god.
I was more concerned for the moai.
I want to go to the beach.
Is that a pig on wheels?
Is that yours?
My dermatologist says somebody's gotta shave me.
Somebody shave me!
Wait, am I going to Hey man, can you spare a minute to shave
my back?
That's not his back, but that's fine.
Dude, that was nanosubular.
Okay.
And that worked, I suppose.
Let's go check in at reception.
My son is crawling with polygons and you terrify me.
Minky, I didn't do anything.
Welcome to Kaitaka's Arce.
cable television and the stereo buffet thank you wait she's
she's got no we have some freshly formatted rooms available
it's just a skin tight suit do i look like the complaints
department of course i am sorry oh my gosh hello aloha aloha
don't keep you waiting yep you'll remember is four or five.
Thank you.
I'm afraid clowns is not a literal card, please, if you get
the opportunity.
The guest book?
Okay.
I was looking at it, actually.
What we got here?
Poly, blank.
I'm so rude.
A cocktail lounge.
Okay.
I've got crabs.
I'd like to give you crabs for dinner.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
This night just keeps getting better and better and better
and better.
If we'll find my mouth, please let me know.
Oh, he doesn't even have a mouth.
What can I do you for?
Give me one on the rocks.
Give me the rocks.
Actually, yeah.
Leave out the one and just give me the rocks.
Give me the...
Your best soil.
I'm actually from Edinburgh.
This is just bronzo.
I only speak sock puppet.
Sock puppet.
Sounds like Vicky.
Marriage license!
Welcome to wedding cake.
What is a four player?
Choose your honeymoon destination.
That's not a honeymoon destination.
Oh, it won't let me choose anything else, though.
Wait, unless...
Oh, it's not Wasta anymore.
Suddenly it's...
Uh...
Dark Knight?
Let's go to the chapel then.
Oh.
Welcome to Wedding Cake.
Choose your honeymoon.
Chapel.
Choose your matrimony.
Wait, who is it?
I'm playing as all four characters, but also not really.
What the hell?
It's happening.
What?
Oh, here's a weapon.
I got something.
Okay, I only see myself as...
Oh, I got one!
I got one!
I'm, like, in the top left.
I should have just picked one player, maybe.
Pre-nuptual agreement.
Not the pre-nub!
Don't you love me?
You would love me!
You would trust me!
I won't sign the pre-in!
It's
the one that picked it up.
Maybe.
Oh, nice.
I got a cake.
What?
Is this Fortnite or?
Just only look at the top left, you guys.
Maybe that's health.
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
No!
I didn't even get a single-headed.
Oh, yes.
This is where we like to...
This is what we like to get.
How...
When does this end?
I'm
not sure.
Civil Union.
Ah.
That's why Zeshi won their ping.
Oh, wait, no.
Their ping is crazy.
Welcome to Wedding.
cake that was fun whoa we're talking a wallabar oh talk a
wallabar you say answer from wherever carnival people here
are strange i think they needed the vacation please smoke in
this area what oh this is fork and knife who are you most
people don't deal in cash anymore do you know who i am any
spare chains i'm sorry i'm sorry you know what happens to
the last pack okay the lounge is interesting yeah they're a
little out of it because they're so relaxed the wet bar
what's the difference can i climb i can't excellent
parkourmanship thank you
No!
Please!
I want to live!
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
We're going... Oh!
No!
Climb!
Dang it.
Hello!
What floor was I on?
Or 405, right?
I operate this elevator with my mind.
See that roof?
Damn.
A lot of birds together.
Birds of a feather, I suppose.
Who's that?
Am I gonna see something I really don't want to see?
Interesting.
Oh!
The fourth floor is the most luxurious.
Nice!
You can see the faces on the balcony.
405, this is me.
Whoa!
Holy moly.
What a room.
Hello.
It's a secret man on site.
Faulty ring, opportunity is to pass out.
Sorry, Polyglot.
Change your plans.
That word is a syndicate man on site.
Faulty ring off its imagery to pass out.
I provided a duplicate attach case.
until you just track them, then swap the cases.
Check the bathroom.
You'll have to guess the outlet to get close enough.
Head on to the end of the bar once you're feeling a little
classy.
Look for the mouth to hone in glasses.
Owen Polyglot.
Watch your back.
SpongeBob?
Oh, massage bed.
That's a lot of money.
Well, this one too.
Oh,
I want a massage bed.
What's this?
Yes.
All right, let's...
Oh!
No, stinking way.
Probably fine.
Um, I don't really wear lipstick much, so...
Don't worry about it.
I'm all gussied up and ready to meet a guy.
Hello?
Did you order room service?
Ah, yeah.
What about you, sir?
Just try.
I'm a little girl, so I'm exploring darkness.
Oh, it's you again!
Everybody's here, everybody's here!
My kiss mark didn't stay on the door.
How will they know that I'm into them?
How will they know?
It should have been me.
Should it have?
What?
What happened to the bird?
I'm a horse.
I'm a horse!
I can eat.
Keep eating my taco.
Oh, hello.
I'm the horse.
Not anymore, though.
Sad.
I love kissing wows and getting diseases.
Nice.
Shortcut.
What are these?
Slippers?
Elementary physics, polyblank.
Elementary physics.
I am a physics professor.
Quickly, polyblank, into the portal.
What?
Oh.
Oh!
Slippers.
Well, at least the atmosphere is breathable.
Look over there, that newspaper box.
What about it?
Oh, I kissed it.
What language is that?
English!
English?
Another dimension of pure madness.
Where did it take me?
Alright, maggot.
Drop in, give me 20.
No.
Give me five.
Come on.
One.
Two.
Three.
Four.
Five.
Alright, get up.
Cut the hell out of my face.
I saw a mermaid, you guys.
Oh my gosh, there's she is.
Wait, everything is underwater.
What happened?
Oops.
I didn't mean to kiss it.
Go home.
I don't like it here.
I don't want to keep kissing the walls of this unknown
dimension.
A different time, a different dimension comes out into the
wormhole thing.
Okay.
Slipper.
Are we back home?
Oh, no.
I don't like the look of this dimension.
Everyone's a cowboy.
I can't even read this language.
Society reverts to Wild West.
Nixon voted local sheriff.
Yay.
Oh!
They both died.
Are you in love with me or something?
Oh.
What can I do with you, sir?
Technically, I'm not allowed to serve as two humans.
Oh.
Give it a try.
Okay.
Let's go.
Hey.
I like to add a dash of cyanide for flavor.
I'm not legally palpable.
I think we're about to die.
If you feel blind.
Guys?
It was so nice knowing you all.
What is this?
Oh my god.
Racing game?
Chance!
Hey, how am I supposed to break it anymore, though?
Oh.
Yeah!
You win.
Woo-hoo!
I underestimated your hand punch style.
Oh, he's fine.
He's fine.
This is a funny area.
Everybody's cowboy.
Someone's flying in the air.
Hello.
How are you?
He's a bug on my shoulder.
And that, oh, there really is a bug on her shoulder.
Get it off, get it off, get it off.
What doesn't, what she doesn't know won't kill her.
Wait, so am I back home or...
Pardon me, my good Samaritan.
I've taken notice of your propensity for performing very
often.
Shall we say unfunded favors for the inhabitants of these
most profitable predators?
Punch!
Are the maps pontificating?
Whether you'd be so good.
What is this?
Rear pool is under maintenance.
I think we're basically back at the normal...
Oh!
Besides being in the wild, what?
Elementary physics, polyblank.
Elementary physics.
Where else can we go?
Quickly, polyblank.
Into the portal.
Slippers!
Unless it takes us...
Master Bollyblank, I find this jumping is becoming far too
risky.
Oh, this looks normal.
Okay.
You should totally go check out the beach.
Yeah?
They won't let me.
Oh, there we go.
I'm just trying to walk into oncoming traffic.
So we have to go to the bar.
That was the thing we had to do to go see the guy.
I...
There was somebody, remember?
He was hiding behind a little thing.
I'm so glad they chlorinated the ocean.
All those sea creatures were gross.
No, my fish!
It was like behind here, right?
Oh.
Yeah, there he is.
But this is a sea critter.
No way.
It's exactly what he wants.
What is this guy doing?
Uh-oh.
Would you like to know my hotel room, don't you?
Yes, please.
You ever had a good one, baby?
I hope you're safe.
Oh.
I thought he was going to, like, give me money or something.
I was like, God, you found me.
I've been standing in the stutter for months.
I love that I can just be like...
Perhaps you'd like to meet later.
Yes, sir.
Find me at my hotel room.
Number 102.
He might.
Yeah, he might.
Yo, how's it going?
Everybody's falling head over heels in love with me.
I can't stop kissing.
Okay, let's go to the bar.
Oh.
What a noise.
Kiss the crowd.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, treasure hunting?
You've got spam.
Japan.
Wow.
Is there more in here?
What is this?
Wait, what is this?
Oh!
Return the tape.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, there we go.
Hold on.
Wait, one moment.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes!
Okay, now I go.
Now I go back to the bar.
I know I only have an hour until my collab, so...
I know, I know.
It's okay if I play right up to it.
Oh, um.
It's all good.
Yes?
Can I help you?
There's crabs everywhere.
This is so fun though.
It is pretty fun, right?
This is like exactly...
Oh my god.
Oh, he's a remote pig.
It's exactly like the silliness kind of game that I like.
Welcome to Kaitaka's Arts.
Okay, it's got to be this guy over here.
I just got to give him a big old smooch on the cheeks.
Or is it...
Oh, wait, I don't reckon...
Oh, hey!
We're twins!
I just love your lipstick.
Where'd you get it?
I have no weapon.
Who does your hair?
I am absolutely distracted by irradiance.
No!
Allow me to introduce my hair.
I am known as the editor.
Oh, did I do it?
Oh, he doesn't care about me.
I don't feel for the pity, lads.
Compromise of the lady in red.
Oh, everybody's in to me.
Um, I don't think I should drink this.
But I will.
I swear, I would marry you if I weren't such a playboy.
Oh, no, what?
Yeah?
I trust you know what happens to those who betray me.
Oh, my God.
I love those shoes.
Uh-oh, it was spiked.
It was spiked!
You double-crossing twin, bitch!
You!
I'm a professional!
You look a little pale.
What's the matter, polyblank?
Polyblank, polyblank, wholeblank, wholeblank, wholeblank,
wholeblank, wholeblank.
Uh-oh.
Accepting free drinks on the job.
I know.
Is this my room?
Whoa.
That doesn't look so good.
Okay.
What the heck was going on in here?
What the heck was- wait, this is not the same- wait, this is
not the same room.
Readme.txt.
Hold on, hold on.
Tourist in the stockyard You are in terminal peril I want to
help come to the rear pool Verify you are not shadowed Oh
Not bad He's still there He's so diligent Rear pool, eh?
Rear pool, eh?
The rear pool, eh?
Can I get in?
Oopsie!
Hello?
Yes!
Thank you for how you made it.
I trust you weren't followed.
I have some pretty big information for you.
Yeah?
But first, we'll need to take the necessary precautions okay
just hold still this will hurt you a lot more than it will
hurt me give me the sign when you are ready
I wish a girl would spike my drink she could put a little
tiny mine in there now they can't monitor us you should sit
down there's a trauma couch oh my god uh is that my blood or
sit down to hear intense news i think i must all right
listen carefully okay this resort it's all fake it's
software we are all characters in a simulation it's taken me
decades but i've discovered a way out of here find the
mechanical boar kill it and cook it okay it will lead you to
freedom take this the natives use it for hunting the boar
godspeed polyblank godspeed oh oh my gosh i thought there
was somebody in here like my cat i know the mechanical pig
is that someone said there?
Why?
Oh sorry.
You scared me.
Mechanical pig!
Okay, oh he's got a QR code.
Wait, but I'm blocking it.
Hold on.
Let me move over.
You guys can scan it if you want.
Oh, I'm still blocking it.
Oh, no, it was right here.
Just kidding.
Cook.
It really was the way out.
What the?
Yes, reload.
I'm not quite sure what that is a reference to.
It leads to Gamersup's code name Boomer.
No way.
Whoops.
Continue the game.
Thank you.
Let's go through.
I'm curious what's going on now.
Escape the wetworks.
Whoa.
I knew you had too much ice cream.
your file format.
Where are we?
What are these?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I can upgrade him.
And you!
It's the incredible machine!
I go to the bathroom and come back.
We're escaping the simulation?
Oh, what happened?
Don't worry about it, we're just escaping the simulation.
No big deal.
Can I fall?
Okay, it doesn't seem like a gun.
Zip me up.
Oh, dot zip me up.
What's the other way, though?
This one.
Oh!
I did it again.
Just let me finish this game of solitaire.
Oh
Where did I come- I came up from- let's just go this way.
This is freaky.
History erase button.
My home page is a star.
What's that, man?
Everything's fine, everybody.
That's a job scare.
Yeah, truly.
There's so much I want to explore in here, you know?
For it in favor of the Italic.
The Italic.
It looks like we're just trying to go up there, no?
Well, this leads up, but this...
Is there anything up here?
Oh, oops.
Just this area.
That's it.
Just E.
Whoa!
Up there is also nothing, so we'll just go up this way.
E.
Okay.
So we go this way now.
Oh, what's this?
Activate Dark Knight.
No, I think I'm okay with how you have it.
Just a little bit more, maybe.
Ah.
This looks important.
Oh, you.
Wow, we're so clumsy!
Did you know that the Will-Elm scream was recorded by Shab
Wooly who sang the Purple People Eater song?
What?
Really?
Speaker what?
Oh, ew.
Sentient box.
Speaker what?
Hello?
She's cardboard.
She's...
she's still typing math oh my gosh what's happening there we
go yes please have a seat we've merged business to discuss
what's going on here you may remember me from the resort
hotel I don't know how you escaped oh yeah taking your
precious director in secondary should you wish to see them
alive again please come to 128 avenue make sure to come
alone and no tricks polyglank this message will
self-destruct in five four three two one
what is what is this
oh yes of course sorry
Just doing my job.
Please let her work.
Yes, sir.
I came in with, like, ready to kill bugs, I mean.
Ready to kill.
Oh.
They sound so pathetic when they die.
She's a gamer, Your Honor.
Five out of five.
I'm not, I'm not here to do the dishes.
Well, I'm here to start fires though.
Do I have any pigeons I can put in there?
Ah, it burns.
Smells like burning.
What do you, what else do you need me to do?
The last one you got slowly.
Okay.
Oh, thank you.
I'm the master baster.
We'll just leave that nice and tender, you know.
How's my breath?
It's hard being a goon.
Master, what now?
I mean, you know.
Ah!
Oh, that's why I was in black and white.
Is this a... bidet?
Fine and utilize a bidet.
Alright!
Oh, no, let me in.
Oh, oh!
Excuse me, I'm here to...
win a round of pillow fight I never lose I never lose I
never lose cool I didn't even realize there was a hand there
let's hear oh oh my god what is happening there's too many
gimmicks all of a sudden everything's so It's a strange
thing!
No.
These are- that's the stuff I found earlier.
Oh, that's a witch's brew!
Burn the TV!
Wait, do I need anything in here?
No?
Okay.
Everything's too silly all of a sudden.
I mean, the game is always silly, but even more silly now.
Petty care!
Okay.
Careful!
Ah!
Nice.
Now let's paint our nails.
Okay.
Did that say snail polish?
Ooh, that tickles.
Oh, we're all getting this color.
Yeah.
I love it.
It's my mom's birthday today.
That was so much fun.
Okay, say happy birthday to Craft Mom.
Happy birthday, Craft Mom!
I love this show!
What the hell?
Oh, I made a bit of a mess.
I'm so sorry.
Wanna listen to some compact records?
No.
We'll keep this on.
This is my favorite show too.
The music is so silly.
For a long time after-
Do the scientist.
She's watching Minto on 3D.
I mean when a cute girl asks if you want to listen to some
cute records with her, she...
Never mind.
What's this?
Nothing.
This place is a humongous...
Oh.
Twister.
What?
Bonus stage.
Start.
Yes!
Yes, claw everything!
Claw everything!
$1,200!
Yes!
Yes, yes!
Even the carpet!
The carpet!
It does take a sacred!
I'm a cat!
I don't care about monetary value!
Yes!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
You know, sometimes I watch that video of that avocado kid.
Like, the avocado, thanks!
And I feel like, really, like, you know.
Like, you know, I get it.
I...
I get it.
I kind of, you know, I would appreciate, like, a banana or
something, too.
Snuffle Munchkin!
I missed my cat.
Oh, I think he's back.
Yes, I am the exterminator.
Quick, look behind you.
Over here, Polyblank.
No, over here.
No, no.
A little more.
A bit more.
Okay.
A little, a little to your left.
No, your other left.
Go back, go back a bit.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, my God, he's got a bag.
There we go.
All right.
Ah, Polyblank, we've been expecting you.
I'll get right to the point.
You've taken something of mine, and so I've taken something
of yours.
Yes.
That's the overarching principle.
Okay.
What did I take?
They've taken some of your important directors.
I.E.
me.
Me?
And it's imperative that you get me back in the right hands.
I.E.
My own.
Improvise.
I know you do well by me.
Okay.
Polyblank, I challenge you to...
To?
of sport oh should you prove victorious I will free the
director unharmed wait this is golf or backstage I'll go
first I guarantee you the helmet be a one hint of foul play
home run I must be a bit off today your turn polyblank
please select the sport Uh, oh, uh.
I think I only have one.
I only have one option.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, guys.
We'll be fine.
Probably.
That didn't hit nearly as...
Jelly.
Oh my gosh, wait, he's in the jelly!
Wait, oh no, that's the secretary in the jelly.
Exciting.
What's this?
That's not gonna, like, lower when I get close, is it?
What the?
Oh, do I need to have this equipped?
Okay, here we go.
The consequences are in your hands, Holy Rank.
Come on, come on!
Okay, just a little, just a little nudge.
Like that.
Maybe.
Oh, too hard!
Okay, less hard.
Like that.
Ah!
Lucky guy.
with oh i can ice skate oh is he still going it's the pie
everybody's here
okay what were we doing oh that's right we are number one
you didn't cheat though did you okay i don't think he did i
think he's fine uh right there all right all right All
right, all right, all right.
Maybe, like, there.
That was a bad shot.
Can I do over?
Wait, let me retry a little bit.
Oh, that one wasn't so bad.
That one's so bad.
And then nice and easy.
Straight in.
Yeah!
I wonder what...
I wonder what power is.
Luck appears to be on my side today.
Yes.
Luck.
Does it just stab you with this or...
Oh!
That was a good shot.
Don't let it get you down, Polyblank.
I'm doing fairly well, I'd say.
I'd say, right?
I wonder what it's saying in Morse.
It's a good question.
Ah!
That was in.
Oh my gosh.
We're just getting warmed up.
There's more?
Follow me, and let us begin the gauntlet.
The gauntlet?
Okay.
Ladies first.
is I want blue you may choose any golf cart you wish oh blue
blue follow the editor oh he's
avoiding all the rings why I made it super bad 64 this next
course will require some recreational coagulant colloquially
known as sports gravy sports now I'll allow you the honors
the rings the rings add water please grab a radio control
and prepare for the jibletting of a lifetime okay what's
going on here oh gravy race
Oh shoot.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, oh, oh shoot.
That's not fair.
Okay.
Oh, drift.
Drift.
Yes!
Lap too, baby.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm doomed.
Final lap.
We can make this.
No, please!
Yippee!
You're not supposed to be able to win this.
Oh.
On to the next course.
Okay.
Easy?
How much more of the game is left?
Oh, no, it's a virtual boy.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I'm the heavyweight champion.
I'll let you know, though.
However, I must warn you.
I'm quite the Matrix Maverick.
Not much.
I'm like to call me.
It didn't feel like it.
Oh, press any button.
Oh, yeah.
Some of these, I don't know how I'm hitting them.
Wait!
Oh, shoot.
Uh oh.
No!
Did he just say that he's, that I'm not superior to him?
Really?
Oh, shoot.
Where'd it go?
I can't see the ball.
I thought we were supposed to be punching each other.
Guys, I'm not good at this.
Wait, how did I get two?
When did that happen?
I'm the king of the worm.
How did he?
I'm a little worm.
I'm a worm!
Oh, because I think his also went out of bounds at one
point.
It needs to bounce, right?
Oh my gosh.
I am very frustrated in my performance.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
to get.
Uh-oh.
Oh, that was close.
His ego meter.
I prefer to call this reverse winning.
You get a little tomato like there, buddy.
I believe you need to calibrate this thing.
There's no way you should have been able to win that.
Ow, let me go on the first.
First place for me!
If you would be so kind, is to hand me my trophy.
Water, you stupid.
Oh my gosh, it's smart water.
No,
no playing on the job.
Oh, what's going on now?
You should hop in.
The water is perfect.
Genocide!
Whoa!
Oh, gosh.
I can't even get in.
I'm so thirsty.
Oh, um...
Yeah, let me get you water.
Let me get you water.
Oh, here you go.
Yes?
You're thirsty?
No?
I did press the button.
Yeah, I did.
Oh my gosh, we're getting so many items now all of a sudden.
Okay.
We have so many things.
Hand me my trophy.
Can I make him like a little...
Oh, I'm Edward Scissorhands?
He needs a belt!
His pants fall off!
What the heck is that sound?
If I hold the trophy, can I actually give it to him?
No, interesting.
Well, there's this... What are you doing?
You want to give it a try?
Get my virtue...
I don't want to play again, though.
Leave, please!
No!
Let me leave!
There should be an exit button!
Please, let me leave!
Let me leave!
I already won!
Please!
You will play the game and you will enjoy it!
How am I so good?
I mean, bad.
It's okay.
Just one more.
Okay, good.
I'm super good at this.
I've got to kill you.
Alright, I have all this stuff.
Hand me my trophy.
Okay.
Oh my gosh!
Oopsie.
You thirsty?
Is this the trophy he wants?
She said she was thirsty.
But she doesn't want to drink.
Maybe I grabbed everything I could.
I hear like a...
Whoa!
Neat.
Eh?
Can you dunk the trophy?
Let's try.
Hmm.
Oh, it literally is a blender.
That's crazy.
You want this?
Or this?
Anything?
Oh, oh, I just realized there's this over here.
Oh, wait, no, this is where I went to before.
I'm silly.
And we just drink that, so it's not like I can give it to
her.
Why suddenly am I stuck?
Up?
Wait, can I drive this?
There's a brain in the water.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, can I touch the cooler itself?
Let's try it.
Oh, I can!
Oh, I didn't realize I could.
Oh.
Rebooting brain.
Whoa.
We
got the brain power.
Wait, you think it bugged?
the game is bugged
wait my game is bugged for real wait so if i save i haven't
saved let me save wait save complete
save and reload okay load If you would be so kind, Mr. Henry
my trophy Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, everything is happening
all at once Wait, this isn't...
Wait, uh...
Wait,
the guy is...
Wait, um...
I'm just parched
and creamy bloody Mary are delicious she likes it nothing
it's fixed now it's strange but you know my one weakness is
accolades oh wait oh no I'll have to inflate him modesty
prevents me from well I'm just this one He's so cute!
I feel like an absolute god.
Here we go!
You flatter me, Polyblank.
Oh!
And you're...
You're metal?
Oh, I don't deserve such an accolade.
He doesn't want the promiscuous polynomials.
Uh...
Wait, do I need one more?
Was there something else?
Or maybe I give him the trophy now.
There we go.
Ha-ya!
Save the director.
You want to give it a try?
Where's the director at?
How do I save him?
How do I get to the director?
Uh...
Save the director.
Okay, okay.
Maybe this car instead.
Get back to the direct...
Save the...
Director!
Director, I don't know how to drive a car anymore!
I'm blind?
Wait, am I?
Where is he?
Do you know?
Follow the words?
Oh!
My bad.
Excuse me.
Uh-oh.
Bird strike.
We're fine.
Chop, chop, chop!
26 hours later?
The director is ready for you.
Thank you.
Consume vast quantities of jelly.
It seems they've got me suspended in some sort of a...
Whiskey.
Crockification.
I call a whiskey.
Holy blank.
Please save me before I drink the whole thing.
What the...
You could become a crocodile.
Any, many, many, many more.
Pick...
Wait, wait.
Save and load.
Yeah, yeah, that's a good idea.
Oh!
Oh, Gatorite!
Sorry, old Sam, but a crock's got to do what a crock's got
to do.
I mean, you might as well crawl in my mouth now, because
it's only going to end one way.
No way.
Ah, shucks.
Do I have anything I can give him?
Let's see.
Uh, is that butter?
Oh.
Oh, I'm drinking that!
Oh, okay.
One final drink.
Wow, it's bigger on the inside.
Can I punch that?
Give you a little bit of heartburn.
This is it!
One but a good one.
We did it!
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I don't like the look of that.
Okay, whew.
This game was so silly.
I wish I had a little more time to take my time with some of
the parts, but I feel like I was pretty good at exploring a
lot of stuff.
All right.
My sincerest apologies.
I've left this tech recording here in the event that I ever
get transmogrified into a man-reptile hybrid, and you need
to escape the labyrinth that is my digestive system.
I've provided some specially encoded people.
I got a lot of it.
Oh, okay.
Awesome.
That takes me many.
Oh, and just a warning.
I have a particularly violent immune system.
uh-oh also please say hi to my secretary if i eat her for
pudding if i eat her for pudding three two one
yay that was so goofy oh my gosh only my only real complaint
is i wish that there was a way to adjust the audio but how
it looks like.
Yeah, I was so goofy.
That was so silly.
That was a good one.
I had fun with that one.
It was just the right amount of silliness.
Right on time.
Ah, yeah.
Also need to sub- Yeah, the subtitles were like a little...
No marriages.
Oh, I did return one of the...
Yeah.
Oh.
cool just got here can you start over um yeah i will end the
stream and then it will start all over again
that's so funny congrats another game finished another game
well guys i would stick around and chat but i have 15
minutes until my next collab so i'm take a rest for that
amount of time and uh just chill until then we'll raid into
my room but yeah bingo thank you miss lots goes to work but
congrats on another win so glad you weren't softlocked yeah
that would have been so bad imagine if we had gone through
everything and then got softlocked it would have been it
would have been pretty bad i say but all good all's well
that ends well Thank you, everybody!
Thank you for hanging out with me.
If I hang out with you a bit more...
in a bit, then I will.
And if not, if you're watching the VOD, thank you so much
for watching the VOD.
And, um...
Yeah!
Thank you, everybody!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Unless I see you in 15?
Now more like 10?
Bye-bye!
Or a soup.
Thank you.